foreign
[Music]
this is Sky News at 10 our top story
Dominic Robb resigns from Government
after a report into bullying about the
Deputy Prime Minister says the decision
is flawed
the departure kicked off a reshuffle of
Oliver Dowden appointed new Deputy pm
and Alex chalk the new Justice secretary
now the Prime Minister faces questions
over his handling of the case he should
never have appointed it in the first
place along with other members of the
cabinet that shouldn't have been
appointed and then he didn't sack it but
even today it's Rob who resigned rather
than prime minister who acts
also tonight a number of major companies
quit or suspend their membership of the
CBI after rape allegations spark a mass
Exodus
the health secretary says he plans to
pursue legal action against a nurses
Union over strike action this month
cranes missing children we have a
special report on Russian soldiers
taking children from their families and
inter-occupied territory this the ICC
says was actually an organized
conspiracy to abduct children
four days of climate protests begin in
central London with up to 30 000 people
calling for Urgent action
we speak to the rugby player breaking
the stigma around mental health in sport
The Faculty I couldn't do my job I felt
as if I was letting my coaches down
letting my players down letting my club
down and letting all my family and
friends down
and we'll take a first look at
tomorrow's front pages in our press
preview from 10 30.
foreign
[Music]
good evening the Prime Minister has
appointed a new Deputy today following
Dominic raab's resignation from
Government after a report upheld some
allegations of intimidating behavior and
a misuse of power the probe by Adam
Tolley Casey was investigating eight
formal complaints Dominic Robb says he
kept his word and stepped down but said
the decision is flawed and sets a
dangerous precedent tonight we'll take a
detailed look at the findings of the
report and the allegations that were
made as well as gauge what people think
about Mr Rob's resignation our political
editor Beth Rigby has tonight's first
report
Dominic Robb now out of government
but that wasn't possible the publication
of this damning report sealing his fate
and forcing the Deputy Prime Minister's
resignation eight formal complaints
about his conduct investigated by Adam
Tolley KC two of them upheld the fast
from his time as foreign secretary where
his behavior was found to be
intimidating unreasonably and
persistently aggressive and his conduct
deemed an abuse or misuse of power at
the ministry of Justice to another
complaint affirmed Rob found to have
acted in a manner which was intimidating
while his conduct was insulting
that language in keeping with the
testimony I'd heard from some of those
who'd seen Mr Robb's Behavior
the way he would treat people the little
people interrogate people ignore people
he created an awful atmosphere they were
nervous about going into meetings with
him because they feared having strips
torn off them
despite the verdict this a reluctant
resignation Dominic Raab writing to the
prime minister to say whilst I feel Duty
bound to accept the outcome of the
inquiry it dismissed all but two of the
claims leveled against me he continued
in setting the threshold for bullying so
low this inquiry has set a dangerous
precedent it will encourage spurious
complaints against ministers and have a
chilling effect on those driving change
on behalf of your government Dominic
Robb in his constituency today trying to
drive home his defense
almost all of the complaints against me
were dismissed and what this doesn't
give you it's a handful of very senior
officials none of the uh junior
complaints were upheld and I got on and
dealt with hundreds of civil servants
thousands of other people in prison
service in the court service and what
you've got is the risk here a very small
minority of very activist civil servants
with the passive aggressive culture of
the Civil Service the PM except in the
resignation but clearly pained
responding it is with great sadness that
I have accepted your resignation add in
he'd always be grateful for Mr Rob's
steadfast personal support and the
dedication commitment and loyalty he
gave to the role of Deputy PM for the
opposition the person to blame for all
of this mess the PM himself what I think
this shows is the continual weakness of
the Prime Minister because there's a
double weakness here he should never
have appointed him in the first place
along with other members of the cabinet
that shouldn't have been appointed and
then he didn't sack him and even today
it's Rob who resigned rather the Prime
Minister who acts early afternoon new
appointments came Oliver Dowden a long
time soon act loyalist appointed the new
Deputy pm and Alex chalk is Justice
secretary but Fresh Faces do little to
change and uncomfortable reality
in the end Mr Robb's departure was
inevitable after two bullying complaints
were upheld he had no option but to quit
but this is about much more than just Mr
Rob's career it affects the Prime
Minister too three of his cabinet
ministers have been forced to leave
government in the past five months and
you have to ask yourself is it really a
government of Integrity professionalism
and accountability while the prime
minister's backers will say that this
shows he's prepared to clean up his top
table others will argue that it shows a
serious lack of judgment that he put Rob
and others into his cabinet in the first
place either way what Rob's departure
brings back to this place is a sense of
Scandal exactly what this new PM was
desperate to avoid bath Rigby Sky News
Westminster
well Adam Tolley Casey delivered his
47-page report into Dominic Robb's
Behavior to the Prime Minister yesterday
after a five-month investigation into
eight accusations of bullying Deputy
political editor Sam Coates has been
looking at the detail of the findings
this is the report that ended Dominic
Robb's career took five months to write
almost 50 pages Adam Tully Casey upheld
two complaints about the behavior of
Dominic Robb one when he was foreign
secretary the other when he was Justice
secretary let's look at both so here's
from when he was foreign secretary and
Adam Tolley found that the former deputy
prime minister acted in a way which was
intimidating in the sense of
unreasonably and persistently aggressive
he found that his conduct also involved
an abuse or a misuse of power in a way
that undermines or humiliates his
conduct was bound to be experienced as
undermining or humiliated by the
affected individual and it was so
experienced now let's look at his time
as Justice secretary
and here Adam Tolley describes how
Dominic Robb would get frustrated when
some of his steers his recommendations
about proposed reforms hadn't been
implemented in the papers that were
being presented to him and he describes
that there was a bit of dispute over
exactly what dominic Robb said whether
he said the work was utterly useless or
woeful but then Tully concludes on
balance I think that these were the
words used they comprise criticism that
was not in the nature of constructive
feedback they were reasonably understood
as insulting personal criticism
but then there's some of the context
around the behavior at that time this is
also from Dominic Robb's time in the
ministry of justice and he talked to
Dominic Raab who made clear that he
takes a strong view the former Minister
that officials should be prepared to
answer questions about the things that
they're presenting to him and if they
don't he's quite prepared to offer
criticism in the words of tolly
unconstructive criticism what dominic
Robb would do is he'd talk about the
lack of basic information or the basics
that they were able to provide now
Tully's view is that this is
unacceptable he says it's likely to be
experienced as an unfairly personal
criticism by the individual to whom the
comment is directed and was so
experienced by some individuals viewers
will have to decide whether or not it's
right for a minister to get cross
because civil servants apparently not
doing their job
uh but then there is this Dominic Robb
makes another allegation that the
political prior the policy priorities
included including the Bill of Rights
and reforms to the parole system were
not liked by the Civil Service uh
Dominic Rob perceived what he described
as a cultural resistance to these policy
uh items amongst others uh in his remit
so he's alleging that civil servants in
some cases were biased and not doing
what he wants but the most toxic
allegation also from his time as Justice
secretary and that's because there was a
big group complaint that was made to
Adam Tolley a group of Genius civil
servants all working together now Adam
totally admits he doesn't know how many
people were involved but look at this
only some of those individuals in this
group had any direct experience of the
Deputy Prime Minister some had never
even met him at all but were seeking to
support their colleagues I think some
Tories when looking at that sentence
might be wondering whether some people
in Whitehall had an agenda
allegations of bullying have dogged
Dominic Raab for years with civil
servants from more than one Department
raising concerns about his behavior the
investigation has shown a light on
bullying culture in the workplace and
the system around reporting issues in
government departments our political
correspondent Ali Fortescue reports
the corridors of Power are a unique
workplace the long hours the demanding
ministers is it too hard to ask for help
how difficult is it right now for a
civil servant to raise a complaint about
academic if you raise a complaint
against even the most senior person a
permanent secretary in your department
there's a process there if it comes to
complaining about ministers there's
nothing there's not even a procedure
there's nothing laid down there's
nothing written down you have got to
complain under the ministerial code
which means it goes to the Prime
Minister and the Prime Minister decides
whether it's even investigated the Prime
Minister it's a veto and this prime
minister has decided to retain that veto
ministers don't line manage civil
servants but there is a power dynamic in
a high pressure environment I think that
there is a generational issue Caroline
worked in the foreign office and number
10 for seven years the politicians who
get
s are probably facing
um are having to live quite a robust
life you know they are they are
constantly being criticized they're
constantly um undiscrucially they will
feel quite isolated sometimes I think in
their in their departments
um they will have a small political
staff around them who will be
responsible for ensuring that or what
they are trying to do is indeed being
done it does mean that there's a
potential mismatch of expectations
two of The Bullying complaints against
Dominic Robb were upheld but it wasn't
totally clear-cut and it's brought up a
bigger debate Beyond Westminster about
the culture in the workplace and what is
deemed appropriate we've had a shift and
a move away from needing to prove that
somebody intends to upset you or cause
you serious distress and more of a focus
not a complete Focus but more of a focus
on how that conduct is received by the
individual I mean we're probably nothing
like as deferential to our bosses then
perhaps we were a generation ago and
that's a societal shift
in some ways it's probably a good thing
but in other ways there is that Clash
but the verdict on Dominic Robb is in he
was a bully of course he has to go this
black and white thing is gout
tonight he's out of government the PM
says there were shortfalls in the
process it seems all sides agree on that
Ali faulsku Sky News Westminster
Joe Pike is at Downing Street for us
tonight and Joe the resignation of
Dominic Raab isn't the only thing
putting pressure on the Prime Minister
tonight
it certainly isn't June oh I think it's
worth reflecting on the fact that
resignations do not normally happen like
this we still do not know what happened
in the mysterious uh 24 hours between
the report being received at number 10
and by Mr Rob and Mr Rob announcing his
resignation it's very curious certainly
it may be due to the fact that Mr
tolley's report was a little bit more
nuanced than some had been expecting is
it possible that the Prime Minister was
swithering and and even considered
trying to hold on to his uh Deputy I'm
sure that will be questioned about that
in the coming day certainly about 24
hours it gave Mr Robb the opportunity to
craft his narrative to ready his
rebuttal and that narrative narrative
has been dominant today he certainly got
his point out there and it has made a
lot of headlines far more headlines than
the views of the civil servants he said
to have treated so badly though I'm told
tonight many of them feel relieved
relieve this process is over and
relieved that Mr Rob has left government
yes Rishi Suna will be hoping these
headlines of his Deputy now start to
dissipate but as you intubate there
Jillian another a story not going away
and that is industrial action especially
since tonight the health secretary Steve
Barkley has announced that he is going
to try and take the Royal College of
nurses to court over industrial action
they are planning to take towards the
end of this month 48 Hours of industrial
action in England he believes that is
potentially unlawful and they are going
beyond their strike mandate it is though
a high stake strategy because opinion
polls suggest there is high public
support for striking nurses therefore
Julia and I I'd argue uh the two bodies
the government and the RCN are on a
collision course and as I say that seems
a high stake strategy for the government
indeed Joe thank you
and for more analysis from Joe on
today's events in Westminster if you
scan the QR code on your screen right
now you can listen to a special edition
of The Sky News Daily podcast you can
subscribe to the Daily for free wherever
you get your podcast from
the confederation of British industry
known as the CBI is an organization
which acts as a voice for businesses but
tonight it's announced it is suspending
all activity following a police
investigation into two allegations of
rape in the last few hours dozens of
major firms have either canceled or
suspended their membership including
NatWest Lloyds John Lewis meta and
Rolls-Royce our business correspondent
Paul Kelso reports
for almost 60 years the CBI has claimed
to speak for business that that Voice
May soon fall silent after some of
Britain's biggest companies rushed to
end their association with the lobby
group The Crisis began with reports of
serious misconduct including an
allegation of rape against a senior
manager at an office party on the Thames
now a second woman has alleged she was
raped by two CBI employees working at an
overseas office triggering a flood of
companies to suspend or end their
membership including NatWest Virgin
Media BT AstraZeneca Ford and meta
owners of Facebook the companies we're
talking about today they have deep
values and they have leaders who follow
through on that that values within their
own workplace I think after it's point
it becomes untenable for them to remain
in a situation where there is a string
of very very serious allegations
the CBI has already sacked its director
General Tony danker for unrelated
misconduct he says made him a scapegoat
now the organization has effectively
Frozen day-to-day business and signaled
the CBI as we know it may be over
in a statement the CBI board said we
have taken the difficult but necessary
decision to suspend all policy and
membership activity until an
extraordinary general meeting in June at
the egm we will put forward proposals
for a refocused CBI to our membership
for them to decide on the future role
and purpose of the organization
John Lewis is one of dozens of household
name businesses that have walked away
from the CBI and the government has
already said it won't talk to the lobby
group while investigations are ongoing
without the confidence of its members or
the ear of Menace as a CBI can't make
the case for business and plainly can't
promote best practice future is in
serious doubt
the members who've called the cbi's fate
into question will decide if it still
has a voice in the summer Paul Kelso Sky
News
to Ukraine now and last night we brought
you a special report on 15 orphans taken
at gunpoint to Russia tonight Sky News
can bring you the story of Sasha from
Mario Paul who went to 12 years old was
taken from his mother by Russian
soldiers
our chief correspondents Stuart Ramsey
traveled to Kiev to speak to Sasha and
his grandmother
Sasha lives with his grandmother now in
Central Ukraine
this little boy was injured in the eye
by shrapnel from a rocket when he and
his mother left their mariopal basement
to cook food outside
the Ukrainian military looked after them
until they surrendered to the Russians
as Mary Apple fell
taken to a so-called filtration Camp
Russian soldiers took him away from his
mother and sent him to
russian-controlled territory in dunesque
in a cafe Sasha showed me pictures of
his mum
he doesn't know what's happened to her
but the Russians said he never see her
again
how was your mother at this stage what
was she saying
yo
foreign
was saved by his grandmother after
doctors posted his picture on social
media outrage she traveled through
Russia to get him back
what was it like when you saw Sasha for
the first time yeah
um
but the vast majority of children
weren't taken by the military in fact
they were allowed to go on trips
described as basically summer camps and
a respite from the Fighting by their
parents
this the ICC says was actually an
organized conspiracy to abduct children
Nastia stayed in touch with her mum by
sending videos from a camping Crimea the
15 year old showed the room she shared
with two other girls how they celebrated
Christmas
one video shows them on a trip to the
seaside
another they're at a youth club District
this anti-trafficking campaigners say is
the Russian authorities trying to
brainwash the children into thinking of
a new Russian life
they were also being educated on the
positives of Russian culture
when did you think I'm not going home
Massachusetts
foreign
just like Sasha's grandmother nastia's
mum traveled through Russia jumping
through bureaucratic Hoops to get her
daughter back
this was their joyful reunion
other mothers joined her reunited with
their children and taken home
the process of finding the missing
children goes on
Stuart Ramsey Sky news Ukraine
it's being called the big one four days
of climate protest by Extinction
Rebellion Greenpeace Friends of the
earth and more than 200 organizations
calling for Urgent action from the
government it was a protest with a
different field some of the recent
disruption at the snooker and the Grand
National in the last week and aims to
attract tens of thousands of people over
the weekend our home editor Jason Fowle
reports from Central London
[Music]
they could Bang the Drum but who will
listen
today there were different messages
outside each government Department
against coal development
water pollution
oil exploration we're here outside the
department for Net Zero and energy
security because although this
department keeps changing their name
they're not changing what they actually
do inside and what we want to ask them
to do is the same thing that
environmentalists have been asked them
to do since the year I was born which is
to stop the expansion of the oil and gas
we know threats human survival
the climate activist's message is
familiar but this is a new tactic more
speeches less superglue discourse not
disruption this is about encouraging
allcomers to the cause
I'm surprised uh at this at the people
who are coming down in a way because
when we started XR you know I expected a
lot of my friends and family to show up
and this time the invitations landed and
loads of those people who I was
surprised weren't coming are all showing
up and we've got over 200 organizations
backing it so it's good
the main organizers Extinction Rebellion
says this weekend we shouldn't expect
the stop oil style tactics of shocking
stunts like the one this week at the
world snooker championships considered a
turn off to many for example XR promised
not to disrupt the London Marathon
writers such as zadie Smith spoke all
these scientists repeating inconvenient
facts and Brian Eno record producer for
U2 and Coldplay also joined the cause we
think that there's a crisis and our
government apparently doesn't think
there's a crisis it's just not taking
the matter seriously at all I keep
saying to everybody we're all on the
same side in this it's just that some
people haven't yet realized and the
government unfortunately are at the head
of those people who haven't yet realized
even without arrests there's still drama
in the way they deliver their message
but many of their demands come with
consequences and tough decisions for any
government grappling with high energy
prices inflation and a cost of living
crisis but they say in the face of a
climate crisis the silence is deafening
Jason Farrell Sky News
fighting has continued in Sudan today
despite an agreement to hold a 72-hour
ceasefire the Sudanese Army and a
paramilitary group rsf have been
fighting for power since last Saturday
and tonight Sky News understands that
Britain is putting troops and aircraft
on standby at an overseas Air Base to be
ready to airlift Embassy staff and UK
citizens from the country our Africa
correspondent usra albagir has been
speaking to foreign Nationals trapped in
the capital cartoon
[Music]
blasts drown out the call to prayer
a day to celebrate the end of Ramadan is
marked by endless violence
many remain trapped as safe route open
then close including a British teacher
from Coventry there were three big booms
one was massive we just sort of lay here
me and my wife we didn't didn't actually
talk to each other
[Music]
um
and we shook what do you and fellow
Brits feel about how the British Embassy
has approached us
I suppose I'll do it in two words it's
gone from
anger definitely there's lots of anger
in there
to uh comical
I think that I think between those two
is where most of us are uh at least the
Brits that I've talked to
we've not we're not very impressed I
think I put it that way people continue
to flee and volunteers are working
overtime to coordinate their safe
passage white Sudanese Army and rsf are
attacking each other my friend and I are
trying to find best passage for people
to leave their location to another uh
safer place he makes one of many calls
to a friend
asking if her road is safe to use mozap
has helped many to safety including
American researcher Rebecca her calls to
her Embassy were fruitless
I am livid at my Embassy I think that
their advice actively is going to hurt
people all of us Sudanese and foreigners
deserve safety and are at risk because
of this war and while foreigners have
been failed by their embassies we have
all been failed by the Sudanese generals
and foreign powers that placed us in
this situation
foreign
that has felt like a lifetime for the
millions who see no end in sight
Sky News
mental health is a subject seldom talked
about in sporting circles but one rising
star of Welsh rugby has said he wants to
break the stigma around it and announced
he is stepping back from the sport to
treat his own mental health osprey's
scrum half Harry Morgan revealed he
tried to take his own life earlier this
year a warning this report from our
Sports correspondent Rob Harris
discusses suicide and other issues some
viewers might find distressing
this is how all rugby players dream of
starting their careers
[Applause]
Harry Morgan was living the dream at the
Ospreys from his teens but with a hidden
growing anguish few athletes talk about
I always found rugby as my Escape
mental Escape I was always able to take
my frustrations from day-to-day life and
frustrations of losing my grandparents
at a young age to a massive influence on
me
um those frustrations I always took out
on the Rugby field
um but losing that ability to be able to
play through injury
then took away my Escape what are those
thoughts that are sort of going through
your mind at this point effectively I
couldn't do my job and I felt as if I
was letting my coaches down letting my
players down letting my club down and
letting all my family and friends down
stress and suffering built up inside the
scrum half who was already scoring
points for Wales in the Six Nations for
the under-20s
the focus was on physical not mental
recovery thoughts kind of
what's my point in life what is my
purpose I had no purpose whereas rugby
is always been my purpose I'd lost the
ability to play rugby
so I'd lost the purpose that's when the
suicidal sort of
thoughts and planning stuff sort of came
into action after Christmas time then
February it obviously came
to a head where I tried taking my own
life and I don't want to be in this
position again I'm to sit in hospital
with my parents talking doctors about
why I've done it and stuff and seeing my
parents upset
I'd want to be that person anymore
it led to Morgan at 23 taking the
difficult decision this week to step
back from playing the sporty loves
speaking publicly for the first time
about his darkest moments to show
speaking helps to show there's no shame
to show it does get better I think he's
just take every day as it comes just try
and be positive about everything if
something negative happens let's try and
look for a positive within that negative
and flip it on his head so we're not
constantly thinking negative
returning to playing rugby in the future
is a possibility but for now mental
well-being is the priority and Harry
Morgan's mission is ensuring no other
rugby player no other person suffers in
silence
Rob Harris Sky News clandassi in South
Wales